ah
en la región del magreb en el norte de
áfrica ha habido un fuerte incremento de
casos de kobe 19 especialmente en
marruecos que ya es el tercer país más
afectado del continente habiendo
superado los 75 mil casos positivos en
este país se están registrando alrededor
de 2000 casos diarios cifras que no se
habían alcanzado todavía desde el inicio
de la pandemia a los hospitales de las
regiones más afectadas se encuentran
saturados y se ha vuelto a prolongar el
estado de emergencia sanitaria también
mucha preocupación en libia un país
dividido y devastado por una guerra
multinacional desde hace casi una década
y cuyo sistema de salud se encuentra
hecho pedazos según datos que maneja el
gobierno de acuerdo nacional respaldado
por la onu se estarían registrando
alrededor de 1000 casos diarios pero
podrían ser muchos más porque no hay
datos de las zonas que no controla este
gobierno que son en gran parte del
territorio de libia en el caso de túnez
el país menos afectado de la región se
están volviendo a registrar centenares
de casos cada día y argelia es la
excepción es el país de la región donde
y los contagios diarios pero siguen
preocupando las muertes se han
registrado más de 1500 desde el inicio
de la pandemia y aun con menos contagios
que marruecos argelia es el país de la
región más afectado por la tasa de
mortalidad
[Música]
el pico de la pandemia parece ya haber
pasado en el sur de áfrica o al menos el
primer pico en sudáfrica se han
promediado más o menos 1000 casos
diarios en los últimos días lo cual es
sin duda una noticia de alivio aunque
las autoridades han llamado a no bajar
la guardia de hecho no se presentaron
altos repuntes en el número de casos
después de que se relajara el
confinamiento y tampoco he tenido que
usar si algunos de los hospitales de
campaña que se implementaron de manera
preventiva cuando estábamos en pleno
pico de la pandemia otros países de la
región como en la media por ejemplo no
se han visto tan afectados no me bien ya
abrió sus fronteras aunque las
sudafricanas se mantienen cerradas y en
general la región del áfrica subshariana
se esperaba que fuera una de las más
afectadas por la pandemia a nivel global
este no ha sido el caso y tanto los
expertos locales como internacionales
han admitido que encuentran inexplicable
este fenómeno el impacto económico sin
embargo en sudáfrica ya se ha
pronosticado a que iba a ser muy fuerte
pero esta semana obtuvimos por fin en
cifras oficiales y se ha dicho que la
economía del país se ha encogido en un
51 por ciento lo cual es mucho más de lo
esperado y en parte las suspensiones en
las actividades de minería y de la costa
explican esta crisis económica
finalmente sudáfrica también ha
suspendido las pruebas clínicas con la
vacuna de la universidad de oxford
después de que se reportaran algunas
posibles complicaciones con este
tratamiento